um
good afternoon i apologize
for coming late but we i have so much
material because there are so many
topics to cover
on the current situation with
coronavirus in the world
it continues to develop on a very some
track the overall number of those
infected as at
the 7th of october surpassed 36 million
threshold the burden on the systems of
social
uh healthcare social and economic
sectors is growing central
epidemiological situation in the world
will be defined in the near future by
the second week of
the prevalency and the tendency
of the spread of this contagious and
dangerous disease
measures taken in different countries to
counter the pandemic
becoming long-term and they influence to
this is that
extent our everyday life
due to the continued degradation of
sanitary epidemiological situation
in the world including in traditionally
popular among our tourist countries we
would like to address
russia the russians and to ask them to
plan carefully their travels abroad
we have already pointed out that in
today's conditions
real threats of strengthening by foreign
countries their internal current and
restrictions
uh growing including
the risk of a complete or partial
suspension of
transportations for example poland
introduced a two-week
ban on air passenger traffic with 29
countries and fell and strengthened the
national borders regime
many countries keep their sky closed
uh there is uh an increase in the
incidence of coronavirus among russian
citizens in turkey
and to death have been recorded
moreover 50 persons were hospitalized
in turkey eight russian citizens
and in these conditions it's important
for the world community to consolidate
their response capability
and to counter this virus and
the key and constructive role in this
track is played by the who
whose long-standing and recognized
partners russian federation we cooperate
dynamically with this structure
in order to implement efficiently the
global agenda on countering the pandemic
we provide on a regular basis our
expertise financial staff technical and
other resources
to solve a broad range of acute
problems in the area of medicine on the
second of october
four new memorandum on intense with the
who were signed
including on providing by russia of
more than 15 million u.s dollars to
support actions in the healthcare area
including countering coronavirus
the director general of this
organization expressing
its gratitude uh said that the russian
federation remained a state uh
providing valuable assistance to the who
and world community
as the tradition goes i would like to
set some example of our countries
helping and assisting other states
during this difficult period of time
including uh because of the
propagation of the pandemic so on
the second of october to the tubic
mission
of russia medical staff in uzbekistan
was
completed they were there to provide
assistance
with uh countering coronavirus i would
like to remind that the first group
worked in the republic in the republic
from the 16th of august till the
16th of september 15 legion impatient
uh facilities a three-child and virus
hospitals send their specialists
infection disease specialists
intensivists radiologists
respirologists general insurance uh 35
persons in general
the brigade was completely equipped with
all the necessary tools including
personal protection means uzbekistan
hosted meetings with the leadership of
the city of tashkent and different
regions as well as the local authorities
in order to develop a whole package of
measures to prevent
the spread of chronovirus in the country
there were also consultations with
our partners from uzbekistan regarding
the
treatment systems in russia
reorientation of
medical facility examination
of those infected moreover specialists
from
moscow received patients themselves they
participated in everyday go rounds they
worked
in red zones as well they were in
contact of course with the year
local colleagues their counterpart they
gave recommendations
as to how to the treatment system
can be adjusted a brigade of
intensivists checked difficult
patients who were in intensive care
department
uh the activity of russian specialist
was highly appreciated in uzbekistan
their
professionalism working abilities uh the
efficiency of their interaction with the
local medical staff
was highlighted and as a follow-up
uh to the results of the work the
krovsky they had of the group
and macholina intensivists have
given a word spin uh outstanding workers
of health care workers
now i'd like to proceed to the schedule
of sergey lavrov
a minister of foreign affairs of denmark
will visit moscow on the 9th of october
during their this visit the
foreign ministry ministers will discuss
the current state and perspective of
bilateral relations
uh tools to give an impetus to them
and uh cooperation on original and the
national problematic including the
ensuring of security in the baltic sea
region and in the arctics
a visit of the mist
of republic of republic of romania is to
take place
uh from the 11th till the 13th of
october
uh during the visit uh sergey lavrov
and his counterpart will discuss
international problems and
issues of the racial security it's
evident that the attention will be
focused on the
difficult situation with the
nagorno-karabakh conflict russia's
in its national quality and within the
osce means group
has been consistently sparing no effort
in order to
seize hostilities immediately and
establish conditions for the renewal of
negotiations
the parties will bring up a wide range
of issues of
bilateral cooperation cooperation within
the eu csto
cis coordination of the air position in
the united nations
osce uh the council of europe
bsec and other international
organization the
program of uh the
uh head of the armenian foreign ministry
involves
laying the wrath at the unknown soldier
too
um i would like to remind that our
bilateral relations
characterize with their alliance nature
intensive political dialogue at high
level and efficient inter-parliamentary
context
constructive exchanges so between
ministers and agencies we believe that
the official
visit of the armenian minister to moscow
will give an additional impetus to
the cooperation between russia and
romania will uh
contribute to the consolidation of
security and stability in transco casia
on the 14th of october talks between
russian foreign minister
lavrov and minister of foreign affairs
and racial cooperation of italy will
take place
italian minister will visit moscow to
take part in the seventh
meeting of russian italian council and
economic industry
monitoring financial cooperation i would
like to remind that the co-chair
on behalf of russia is uh the minister
of industry
and trait of russia mr montour during
negotiations the heads of
foreign ministries will discuss uh a
broad range of issues of international
agenda focusing on
strategic stability and armed control
special attention is to be
paid to relations between russia and the
eu station on ukraine belarus
belarus and nagorno-karabakh settlement
in libya and syria
moreover cooperation within g20 will be
brought up bearing account the
chairmanship of italians organization in
2021 we are all looking forward to it
it's also um scheduled
uh to exchange opinion relevant
problematic of russia italian interstate
relations
in political economic cultural
humanitarian fields and
[Music]
with regard to the interaction between
civil societies of two countries
another event regards the 13th of
october when uh russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov
will take part in the video conference
dedicated to the
valdar discussion club and its
analytical report utility of
multi-faceted world
history to be continued it is uh
scheduled that the minister will assess
the main tendencies of the
in the global uh situation and will
respond to the
questions of russian and foreign experts
and the site of uh
minister of foreign affairs will
broadcast this uh discussion
and i believe that uh the valdar
discussion club will also
provide us with um video materials
i would like to bring up other issues of
the relevant international agenda in
russia
russia's foreign policy sergey lavrov
appointee the director of the department
of middle east and north africa mr
kenchuk
special representative of the ministry
on the syrian track the diplomat will
represent
russia during literally multilateral
context on theory and problematic
including geneva and austin are formats
aimed at achieving settlement in theory
i would like to remind you that both
formats
are achieving purposes set
forth in the u.n uh security council
resolution i would like
also to mention um
russia's activity in the context of its
interaction with international
organization
including the who russia and the wh o
have been cooperating for decades uh in
implementing major projects on global
regional national levels
for the benefit of the development of
sustainable healthcare
system russia is a key donor of this
organization number of tracks
key of them are countering infectious i
mean tuberculosis and non-infectious
diseases
protection of the motherhood and the
childhood promotion
of the relevant information in russian
on the 2nd
of october russia and the who signed in
geneva for donor agreements
covering the tracks of cooperation i
have mentioned
their overall budget surpasses 15
million us dollars during the
visit of the head of the european
regional
bureau of the who in september
new promising dimension of corporations
were discussed
such as digital medicine russian
expertise is highly appreciated by the
who
our specialists have been involved in
the work
of the special missions and the
expert bodies of the organizations and
due to the epidemic these contacts have
been intensified representative of the
russian ministry of
health care and transparency took part
in number of the who missions
in uh various countries of the world the
professionalism was highly appreciated
by the
governance of this international
organization
which is evidently a part of the united
nations it's not surprising that uh
director the director general of the who
intend to involve our specialists in
their
work another topic
linked to the united nations
i would like to remind that the summit
russia africa took place on the 23rd
24th of october 2099 and the russian
federation decided
uh to increase its
donor input in the u.n world food
program according to the decree of the
government
of the 18th of september this year
humanitarian assistance will be
provided this year to five
african countries highly in need
republic the republic of burundi's
republic of djibouti the federal
republic of somalia republic of sierra
leone is a central african
republic those states are on the list of
the least developed
countries and they are subject to
natural disasters like long-term throats
and heavy rains
station the economy is aggravated by the
continued pandemic
due to the disruption of industrial
change
expert and imports their
capabilities of development are
undermined and
the food securities of large population
group is undermined as well
i would like to remind the wfp is a key
multilateral channel of providing aid
to the population in in need
and its work is not politicized it's
efficient and that's what
make us work together another
international organization
is the
[Music]
black sea region the sec and we attach
great importance to the compression of
this organization i believe that the key
mechanism
in this regard is the osc it includes 12
countries
they form a broad region
of the black sea literal and this
organization
will celebrate its 30th anniversary 2022
throughout this year's organization
proved
its relevancy and
during the recent years uh interregional
trade in the region decreased from 18
percent to
13 percent out of the overall trade in
order to overcome this negative tendency
we need
to promote a unifying economic agenda
that can become an important factor in
consolidating the
overall stability in the region we need
to start implementing practical
agreements
in particular uh with regard to the
establishment of a key
[Music]
freeway around the sea
and the promotion of business
initiatives in order to solve for those
relevant tasks we need to give an
impetus to the work of the secretary of
the organization
which uh slowed down in the conditions
of the pandemic as we know
in june a new three-year mandate of the
secretary general of this organization
will begin
and russia proposed its candidate it's
an experienced diplomat with a bright
and diverse professional biographies
of director of the diplomatic academy
it's an ambassador vladimir zaymsky
who has a vast expertise in bilateral
and multilateral formats truth in this
candidacy
we picked intentionally a person
with a white knowledge of multilateral
diplomacy and interstate integration
we are convinced that it will enable him
to take an unbiased approach
and to analyze the problems of the
organization
and we do not doubt that
once elected he will find efficient ways
to resolve the problem the organization
faces
he will contribute to the
to its dynamic activities in a
non-politicized way
and uh consolidation of the spirit of
cooperation for the benefit of all the
organization members we believe that our
partners will
support the candidates
it had a happy ending
on the 6th of october i would like to
mention
all those who participated in the rescue
mission as a result of which
russian sea men from ryoman tong and
jibalo were released from their
pirates captivity they were transferred
after their release to a secure location
and will soon be sent home
they have been awaiting their release
from the 9th of may this year
the nigerian pirates attacked a
scientific and research
ship gibolo and the rio montyoung
cargo ship in luba in equatorial
engineer
the seamen not only were denied medical
treatment but even water
and food
[Music]
the chance to return home alive
sometimes seemed elusive
nigerian pirates repeatedly threatened
to kill their prisoners
in order to at the very least hydrate
themselves the prisoners had to drink
water from ground wells this is a really
dramatic story
and they are deserving of a literary
work dedicated to them
footage was spread by the pirates
themselves
showing uh ground russian citizens
saying that they had no food no water no
medicine
they they were sick with malaria and uh
they were at the end of the rope already
relatives of the captives have done
everything to ensure
that the prisoners were released
fires demanded a ransom
in the worst practices of such stories
i would like to repeat
the freeing of russian semen was made
possible
thanks to the joint efforts of uh
russian diplomats
in russian embassies nebuchadnezzar
and official toys of the equatorial
genie
as well as ship owners representatives
i would also like to mention that the
call of relatives to
save the sea seamen was answered by
alexari pasca who is well
versed in the realities of africa his
companies
have presence engineer and nigeria and
he has
faced large-scale epidemics in the
course of the operation of his companies
in the countries
and he has also in the framework of
these activities faced
many other difficult challenges we would
like to appreciate
to express our appreciation to everyone
who participated
in making sure that the captives were
released we hope that
up till the end of this week the seaman
will return home
i believe that we should pay special
attention to good news
these days especially when they have
such a great happy ending now
nagorno-karabakh settlement
[Applause]
russia in its national capacity and as
part of the osce means group continues
to make every effort as a mediator
seeking an immediate ceasefire in agony
karabakh
and in surrounding areas resumption of
peace negotiations based on the existing
basic principles and relevant
international documents
the simulator similarity of approaches
adopted by russia the us
and france are evidenced by the recent
joint statements made by the
presidents of the three countries
presiding the osce means group
as well as the joint statement of the
foreign ministers of these three
countries
russian president vladimir putin
discussed the situation with armenian
prime minister
on the second the fifth and the seventh
of october there was also a fun
conversation with the azerbaijanian
president on the 7th of october
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
is in constant contact with his
azerbaijani and armenian counterparts
we are considering different scenarios
uh in trailer we have proposed to make
moscow a platform to organize a meeting
between uh
foreign ministries of russia mini
anderson by china with the participation
of the oc means group
we holding consultations with the
parties regarding the possible time
frame for the start of such negotiations
we will keep you informed
regarding all the steps that are being
taken on this track
[Music]
i would like to say a few words about
events in the union security council on
their syrian chemical this year we would
like to focus attention
on the meetings uh in the u.n security
council to discuss
the cert certain syrian chemical
deceived by western countries we are
talking about
the meeting on the 28th of september
held by
the permanent mission of russian to the
united nations to with the members of
the security council
on the form area formula where
expert evaluations
the opcw platform and the situation
wherein
were voiced by mr henderson
a former opcw inspector a professor of
the massachusetts technological
institute mr apostol
and independent journalist mr mata who
said that the situation in the opcw as
it is now
is unacceptable
[Music]
in the face of such argument based
reports
western opponents didn't have a food to
stand on
they simply fell back as per tradition
on the overused anti-syrian and
anti-russian rhetoric
another similar example
russian president's presidency in the
u.n security council
on the 5th of october at the open
meeting of the
council on chemical demilitarization of
syria
invited a person who stood at the
origins of the opcw first general
director
of the technical secretariat of the
organization
mr bustani of brazilian descent he was
sidelined
under pressure from the us and their
allies
since he tried to hold an independent
position
on the relevant issues on the agenda of
the opcw
western countries once again showed
their reluctance to even hear out
inconvenient evaluations of a person who
is
acknowledged professional in the field
they simply stopped
mr bustani from addressing the
participants
of the meeting
arbitrary actions in the field of
politics and
legislation is something that
western countries use in the opcw and
now they began to use it also in the u.n
security council
it is deplorable the technical
secretariat
of the opcw is also a matter
on the agenda we received a question
from a media outlet
whether we intend to request a full
version
of signatures on the report of the
final final mission regarding the
situation with navalny
this is a quite a reasonable question we
will
ask the technical secretary of the
organization to provide
full information after
the results of the laboratories
estimated to the task come
back these data alongside with
answers four requests have been sent
to berlin by the
attorneys general office
have been sent this will be necessary to
conclude
the investigation and find out whether a
crime
was committed in regards to navalny only
if this is true then criminal action can
be taken
this issue will be addressed separately
later in my briefing
right now we are talking about the
technical secretariat of the opcw
we would also like to
once again repeat
our demands to return
illegally taking out material evidence
from russian and to provide russian law
enforcement with access
to maria perchi in order to question her
as a material
witness in the events and also provide
our medics with an opportunity to take
the materials from the blogger himself
till our demands are not met we will
continue to state
that the whole story
is a simple matter of mystification
unfolding due to
an increased pressure sanction fraction
against russia i would once again like
to return that
we are talking in the context of what is
going on in the technical secretariat of
the opcw
but there is another track that is
rapidly developing due to the
story of the russian blogger we have
taken note
of the information circulated in the
media regarding abundance meeting
with the special rapper term
in berlin with a special rapporteur of
the
hrc on extra judiciary killings
mr kalamar and on the matter of freedom
of expression
mr han in the course of which the
russian allegedly
asked them to conduct an international
investigation
of his poisoning what can we say
to that respect taking into account that
we have received many questions
at the end of august russia has received
a request from the aforementioned hrc
special reporters
asking to comment upon the situation
with navalny
even though
the human rights council
can only make non-legally binding
recommendations in
its interaction with countries
in order to respond to the request made
by the special rapporteurs
we did send to the relevant russian
structures of our country
including the attorney general's office
the relevant inquiry
as of today
the procedural inspection initiated by
russian
investigatory authorities has yet to be
concluded
i will reiterate once again it has not
been concluded because german france
and sweden are unwilling to fully
cooperate in a full objective
and comprehensive fact-finding
proceedings in order to establish the
truth as envisaged by the european
convention
on mutual legal assistance in criminal
cases from the 20th of april 1959
and the supplementary protocols from the
17th of march 1978 and the 8th of
november 2001.
under the information convention and the
supplementary protocols
our country sent six requests to germany
france and sweden requesting legal
assistance
to carry out questioning of navalny they
are treating
physicians and accompanying people as
well as to provide copies of medical
documents relative to his treatment in
berlin
expert researcher of biomaterials and
other objects
as well as other research carried out in
france and sweden
unfortunately instead of working
together to find the truth about what
has happened with a russian citizen
official paris and berlin opted to
politicize the matter
and switch to threats and blackmail
using international platform centralia
we believe such
behavior unacceptable and irresponsible
from our part we hope that the request
of the hrc special laboratories
regarding
the events related to mr navalny will be
sent
to germany all the comments and all the
information
that we share with the public is
available to them as well
and we hope that they will thoroughly
analyze it
we also continue to advocate for the
most thorough
and objective investigation of this
matter i would also like to say that
according to the blogger to the russian
bloggers himself
the investigation quote is not being
conducted
and quote which was the main reason he
addressed
the special reporter we can responsibly
state
that this is another example of
mispresenting information
perhaps in order to manipulate the
public opinion
in reality
activities are being conducted at the
relevant levels
this is known to everyone
we have repeatedly addressed the matter
today it was reaffirmed by the
investigative
committee of the ministry of interior of
russia
the information is available to everyone
in the materials
reasons that prevent the investigation
from going forward are also
listed all these materials materials
should be read
now we'd like to proceed to the
information
regarding our american partners we
pointed our attention to new declaration
by washington regarding the deployment
of shock
weapons in the space it is another
manifestation
of the uh policy
of the united states in the space and
that achieving supremacy there
the plans to weaponize the space outline
several times by the united states
uh such summer's representation exists
it means
the deployment of weapons and uses
as the arena of military actions it's
uh just a part of the doctrine of the
united states in this area said force
in the defense space strategy and the
document of the space force of the
united states peace power
in order to justify such actions
washington uh uses traditional
stereotypes and claims about
the russian the chinese threats in the
space it's a
part of the targeted information
campaign of the united states to
demonize
russian space activity and our
initiatives to prevent space harm in the
uh to prevent armed race in the space
our american colleagues try once again
to distort the situation to drag the
attention out of
real threats in the space we confirm our
commitment
to the obligation to use and research
make researches into space in a
nondiscriminatory way
our actions do not violate any norms or
principles of the international law in
contrast to the united states we don't
have any plans
to achieve superiority in the space
we do not have any plans to put shock
weapons in orbit
and it is confirmed by the proposals
on by russia with the support of a
large group of associates uh in this
area
i mean the development of the
multilateral legally buying agreement on
preventing
armed race in the space on the basis of
the russian chinese pro
draft treaty on preventing i'm raised in
the space and on use of threats
there and not to be the first to deploy
weapons there
we will continue to work
aiming to achieve specific results we
call
upon washington once again to
demonstrate prudence to renounce from
dangerous actions that
can be uh of consequence not only for
the united states but for the whole
international community that's not the
only one question uh
related to the united states and the
policy they are conducting
uh with regard to the whole world and
russia in particular i have to comment
on the
statement by mark aspen head of the
pentagon who visited
the american military cemetery on the
surges of september
statement in his point of view russia
supposedly
is supposedly conducting a predatory
malevolent
and violent policy in order to
destabilize
the resources of african country and to
steal them it's threatening
the regions in order to expand
its influence there in order to prevent
it he proposes
to be guided by the united states who
allegedly can
guarantee stability and prosperity i'd
like to bring up the
question as to what prosperity and
well-being
is meant
maybe they mean another libyan scenario
or
maybe that's what uh the head of the
pentagon wants to propose to the
american continent i would like to
remind
that after the illegitimate intervention
by
nato the country was dragged into a cast
and became
the source of original instability the
hotbed of
terrorism and violent extremism
this the prosperity and well-being that
the united states want to ensure to the
region and
other regions as well is it what is
meant i would like to remind to mr esper
that russia has never interfered into
internal affairs of other states
its distinguishing our policy
from the policy of the united states who
bluntly
impose a will on other states using
economic propaganda force and other
leverages and they believe that they are
in right to tell others how to behave
and with whom to cooperate
at the same time they conduct
policies that undermine the basics the
fundamentals of culture
of traditions upon which
societies were built and
when it happens the united states just
move on and they would like to erase
this from the history
there are numerous examples of that and
our american colleagues have to
recognize that new colonial attempts to
import their will to sovereign states
are refuted
by the absolute majority of the
international community members and i
believe that
african country cannot can
make the decision independently
without any hints from other countries
they
are well aware of their history and they
know
who supported them throughout
the 12th uh 20th century
and they know who robbed them during the
20th century and other periods of time
that's not all i would like to say with
regard to the united states
a report of the ministry of
internal security of this state was
published with the assessment of threats
that the state is facing
now and do you know who threatens
this country most of all russia isn't
listed there
they claim that it can use the existing
possibility in the area information
communication technology in order to
undermine
vital american electoral infrastructure
and to try to have an influence
on the preferences of the electorate
and in the same report
there is no statistics from the
american budget with regard to the
resources
dedicated to sustaining informational
uh technologies vital american electoral
infrastructure and so on and so forth
where is this money spent
if one single country can
undermine all of this and there is a
whole report about it
of course it's deplorable that the u.s
administration because of some political
consideration
wastes much human material resources in
order to promote
russian sentiments among their citizens
and the world community
instead of this mad attempts to
accuse russia of everything and to
present
the situation as if it's uh approaches
to
security in the information
area can have an anti-american character
i would like to suggest that american
colleagues have a look once again to the
statement by president putin of the 25th
of september
where he proposes to renew russia
american cooperation in the area of
international information security
it says it all and the moscow is
expecting a reaction we believe
we hope it will be meaningful
now i would like to say a couple of
words of the alleged
russian interference in electoral
processes
in the united states the chamber of the
representatives of the united states
congress was submitted on the 30th of
september and as a draft lore on
preventing foreign intervention in
american elections
could you imagine how many reports
resolutions
other documents and statements petitions
are submitted and printed
practically every day in the united
states
even though they're dedicated to the
main topic about the
uh they dedicated to iteration in
american elections
if it's the main topic it has been the
main topic for many years
you have to do something because it's a
waste of time to print all these
statements to endlessly talk about it
because
when you read the statements we
understand that people cannot be serious
though the authors of another such a
report
proposed to introduce
rigorous and tough economic restrictions
against leading
banks and enterprises of fuel and energy
sector
and the question arises all the times
as to whether they want to protect the
electoral system from
interference from other countries or
they want to invent
a pretext to restrict to limit
the activities of russia and a whole
number of tracks
even though these two topics have
nothing to do with each other
the topic of the alleged interference of
russia in the united states elections
is has been discussed for many years
and legislature in washington do not
call down they
don't even get tired of producing
iteration initiatives
and of the terms to punish our country
and other competitor countries
for in their influence on lecture
processes
we have commented on these uh
accusations number of times
unfortunately such uh kind of
tools are being applied in the internal
policy of the united states and on this
level it's uh
impossible to continue a meaningful
dialogue with washington it's
becoming more and more difficult but we
do not lose hope of course
and we hope that upon the complexion
of pre-election discussion
the reason will prevail and
it's not the imaginary threat
of the russian interference will attract
consensus
on in the congress but the understanding
of the necessity to
start solving the most difficult
problems
and the last thing i would like to say
about this electoral
syndrome in the united states
i would like to highlight that what i've
said is
but may be difficult to be comprehended
by
the american establishment
that's why i will say a very simple
thing
those are not us who interfere in our
elec
in your elections now you track
intentionally the whole world
and your electoral processes now i'd
like to set a specific example
by the way it's as outrageous as the
previous ones
it's an example of how the united states
interfere in
other states internal affairs the
example is nicaragua
a forum was held by the state department
dedicated to the subject
named nicaragua a free and fair
elections are possible it was announced
that the trapped electoral
reform of the country was received from
nicaraguan a position
and it's allegedly intended to be
envisaged and submitted to the action
government of nicaragua
we understand very well the
attitude of fashion to their neighbors
in the region and latin american
countries
their attitude was outlined a number of
times but there are really outrageous
things so it
is implied that the document before
being sent
to the addressee was
presented to the third party and the
broad public
in order to be discussed and
even approved of and there are the
threats of new sanctions
if the government of managua
did not satisfy the relevant
requirements i would like to ask
our colleagues in washington have you
ever imagined yourselves
in the place of this country day by day
you are chasing the imaginary idea
of external interference in your
electoral process
at the same time you try to impose your
recipes to sovereign states you threaten
with
some punishment if something in their
foreign policy does not satisfy you the
united states
unstabilized destabilize the internal
political situation in many states latin
america
is not an exception we condemn such
practice we believe that the
way to resolve the problem
is to be based on international law
and not on some invaded by
somebody somewhere rules
in jesus rules uh do not correspond to
moral principles or the
lore there is no alternative to solve
internal political disputes
[Music]
but inclusive dialect
experts in the united states
are written in donald trump's decree
regarding the extension of limitations
against a number of governments
for i quote not doing enough to
counteract human trafficking
according to the document published on
the 1st of october
on the website of the white house
it concerns the funding of cultural
and educational exchanges in cuba dprk
and syria we have
reaffirmed our position
which is which comprises the rejection
of western counties of the concept of
modern slavery
to prej to the prejudices of the human
trafficking we believe this is
a tool to interfere into
the affairs of sovereign states we are
interested in an integral and
comprehensive consideration
of the human trafficking problems we
promote our position
in different platforms and we advocate
for our substantive dialogue
and a balanced approach taking into
account all the aspects of this
multifacetous phenomenon we consider
that concrete practical cooperation
direct contacts between the relevant
police
units migration services border control
agencies
as well as other platforms exchange of
experience meetings
between experts are highly important
to solve the present issues related to
human trafficking we believe that
country projects
aimed at fighting human trafficking
should only be implemented once a
request
is sent from the interested state we
believe that every state
is entitled to independently determine
the most suitable
mechanism to contract human trafficking
we believe that a situation when a state
asserts its right to provide evaluations
to others believing itself to be more or
less advanced in fighting human
trafficking
is first not conducive to resolving the
problem as a whole and secondly
it does not meet the standards of
international relations in the
conditions and in the circumstances
of the multilateral world
on the 6th of october following twitter
and facebook
instagram joined the practice of
randomly marking accounts and
publications of russian mass media
as state controlled we see that such
actions
are discriminatory and have a
coordinated
character when american monopolists at
the market of social networks
are using other sources in order to
influence
national information sources
which is evidence evidences their
political bias
and intent to align their actions with
the foreign policy
adopted by washington at the moment such
a mark
and if we refrain from instant word we
can say a brand
which instagram administrators
hypocritically call
a warning is applied exclusively to
reuniversity and artist accounts
as well as their news products western
mass media with
state funding are not subject
to such markings
trying to justify these obvious double
approaches
instagram references that the use of
a certain specially developed system of
evaluation
is what allows them to determine whether
this or that
media is controlled by state
should we say that criteria for such
moderation
are highly non-transparent the most
surprising and possible is another thing
from instagram's explanation it follows
that its administrators can
independently make the decision
to determine whether the policy of the
media is independent
and whether a media outlet serves the
interest of society
this is a quote we could suppose
that such
high self-esteem and confidence of
their social network which allow them to
see themselves
as a judge atop of the world who
controls the well-being of the whole
world is dictated by the american
illusion of exclusivity however
there is a simple explanation such
unpopular and anti-democratic
steps made by such companies
as the result of political pressure from
the american establishment
which for them to follow the track
aimed at discrediting russian media and
driving them
out of the world information space we
are disappointed
that instagram is celebrating its 10
years anniversary
to suit the interest of censorship
promoted by the united states against
the media of our country
we call upon the administration of
instagram to review their policy
since it limits the right of consumers
and users
to free access to information we're
reminded any actions
of moderation of online content should
be transparent they should not limit
access to any information source
based on its political or other
conventions
as well as other characteristics which
could lead
to discriminate discrimination against
anyone
we hope that relevant international
structures and human rights
organizations will respond accordingly
and give their
impartial evaluation of such restrictive
actions by american social networks
lithuania the second round
of negotiations is over in the court of
appeals of lithuania
on the tragic events in vilnius on the
13th of january 1991 russia's official
position on the matter is well known
the whole trial we see as a continuation
of the vicious policy pursued by the
lithuanian leadership
in order to falsify history and settle
historic scores with russia
we see their trial
as a trial in flagrant violation of the
basic principles of international
justice
and a serious try against the authority
of lithuania as a member of the eu and a
member of the european convention on
human rights away convinced
that the track chosen by lithuania does
not correspond to the national interest
of lithuania
and its people who are interested in
restoring
good neighbor relations with our country
i would also like
to state that
on the 20th of september october
the 20th of october marks the 75th
anniversary of the beginning of the walk
of the international
tribunal nuremberg which resulted in the
sentence to the officer perpetrators of
atrocities master and killings genocide
horrifying destruction and plundering of
large territories in this regard on the
20th and 21st of november in the museum
of victory at buckland
mountain a special forum lessons of
norman
will be held as part of the year of
memory and glory
panel discussions will combine
the matter of preserving history and
memory and the role of the numbering
process
in creating the modern world order as
well as matters of national security and
national education
of the youth panel discussions uh
will also sum up the experience and
bring into account those who managed to
evade punishment for
war crimes as well as matters related to
practical implementation
of international criminal law formulated
by the nuremberg
tribunal as part of the thematic
platforms
uh roundtables will be organized in
order to
ponder upon the historic significance of
the energy process and the role of the
soviet union
in halting responsible the responsible
war criminals take count
the parties will exchange views on the
different
aspects of applying the decisions of the
tribunal
it will also analyze how this process
can be reflected in art
and how it can be used to foster the
education of the young generation
organizers
of the thematic platforms and discussion
panels
will be ministries and agencies as well
as leading scientific and research
institutes and
public organizations the foreign
ministry alongside with the ministry of
justice and the attorney general's
office
will organize a thematic panel entitled
the heritage of nuremberg in
international and national
law russian and foreign legal experts in
international law will participate
and the parties will be able to exchange
scientific and practical experience we
invite all those interested in this
topic to
assist first and foremost we are talking
about russian and foreign
media representatives uh to cover these
uh scientific and practical
event uh questions about accreditation
should be addressed to the press service
of the central museum of the great
patriotic war
another topic i would like to address
since we received many questions
we are talking about the settlement in
afghanistan
unfortunately almost a month has passed
during
the launch of the interrupting
negotiations but the parties
still continue their consultations on
the procedure
the situation unfortunately resembles
a deadlock we are concerned by the
broken down
of the dialogue in qatar
as a result dozens of people are dying
every day
we call upon the delegations of kabul
and the taliban
to conclude their technical procedure
negotiations as soon as possible
and proceed to negotiations on the
substance
in order to decrease the level of
violence in afghanistan
mali we continue to follow closely the
situation in the country
at the end of september in accordance
with the demands of the
ekkovas acting as a mediator
in mali to transfer authority in the
country from
the national committee of popular
salvation established by the military
to civilian leadership president and
prime minister of the republic for the
transitional period
were appointed the former defense
minister and the foreign minister
the head of the committee became vice
president on the 5th of october a
transitionary government
was formed comprising
the representatives of the main
political parties and movements in mali
we believe that the appointments we have
mentioned is a step in the right
direction
that evidence is that a gradual return
of the situation will lead to the
constitutional track in this context we
welcome the echova's
lifting on the 6th of october sanctions
it introduced earlier against bamako we
hope that temporary interim authorities
in mali will do their best in order to
restore civic forms of government in
malay as soon as possible based on
an inclusive nationwide dialect and hold
and after
a transitionary period to hold
democratic elections so with
participation of ekovos and
the african union we hope that the
country will be able to overcome the
crisis
and we seek further gradual development
of
the whole range of mutually beneficial
cooperation between russia and mali
another topic which causes many
questions
we have received many
it is also addressing many biased
statements made by
our western colleagues
germany's agency has made
an interesting statement as well as
french ambassador on the 30th of
september regarding
russian citizen metro
he was accused of violence against his
uh
minor daughter
we believe this to be interference into
the internal affairs of the russian
federation
and an attempt to put into question the
decision of independent
judiciary authorities in our country
would also like
to point out that such
actions are groundless and the sentence
should not only be seen through
the to the perspective
of human rights his previous
activities and his achievements
have nothing to do they are not in doubt
the matter of his sentencing is uh
covered by our criminal legal framework
and in this regard we see calls
from berlin and paris representatives to
release
the accused of pedophilia dmitriev as
immoral
and unacceptable
the protection of miners from sexual
crimes
should be illegal and well and
moral value regardless of the
circumstances and
this here i would like to also say that
we monitor such statements
and we hear them not only from berlin
and paris we
also hear them in different countries
when foreign ministers or
other officials
believe it appropriate to make such
conjectures
in this regard in the nearest future
we will ask
representatives of embassies of these
countries
to come to the minister of foreign
affairs who will send the relevant
invitations to
the embassies of the countries that make
such inappropriate
statements
saying that the case
has a politicized character
and advocate for the support of dmitrif
explaining to their public that they are
protecting him from arbitrary reactions
we will invite them and we will
ask them certain questions and provide
them with certain information perhaps
they do not have the necessary data
we will write
this situation and provide the necessary
materials
and we will continue
to watch as to
how they can assess the facts it is
still
relevant and we consider such statements
as an interference into our internal
affairs
there are also good news on the 3rd of
october
we celebrate it very important to van
the 20th anniversary of signing
the declaration of strategic partnership
between russia and india i would like to
remind you that this document said to
basis for the development of the whole
area of interaction between our country
in the multiple
world it's one of the
first partnership initiatives
which has become a normal practice in
international relations one of our
priorities a
close coordination of our external
policy efforts
the increase in
turnover in our trade the
development of our cooperation in
investments in the area of finances
we approaching this year in very
difficult conditions
so of a new chronovirus infections
and we are actually cooperating in the
issues of the
production of vaccine against
coronavirus we intend to continue
cooperation in traditional areas such as
energy
the researchers in the space and we are
going to focus
on such promising domains as cooperation
in the forest in the arctics
on the issues of the construction of the
infrastructure
and facilities that collect
us it is believed that the country
cannot have
permanent allies or enemies and all
interests can be
immortal but we believe that russia
indian relations go far beyond that
because it's a unique example
of an immortal
friendship on the basis of which uh
there are
equality and rights mutual benefits
and uh taking into account each other's
national interests
and on the 8th of october we will
celebrate
40th anniversary of the signing of the
treaty on friendship compression with
syria it's
one of the agreements signed on behalf
of the ussr
which stays relevant even today
and it's recognized by russian
federation the syrian arab republic
we are positive that russian syrian
relations passed the test of time
including uh thanks to the careful
approach to their legal basis
that proved its efficiency during the
turning point of the history it gives us
the reasons to be optimistic about the
future of syria
and to see broad perspectives of our
continued
fruitful cooperation with this amicable
country in all the areas
of committed partnership the 9th of
october is also an important today the
republic of uganda is celebrating the
58th anniversary of the proclamation of
its independence in the 15th and the
17th
century major state entities appeared on
the territory of modern uganda but
however
after the colonial division of this
territory in 1895
british protectorate was established
there in only 1962 the people of uganda
achieved its independence it's another
question
to our american partners as to who wrote
the african
continents and how we'd like to remind
that the diplomatic relations between
our countries
were established on the 13th of october
1962. we highly appreciate the
traditional amicable character of russia
ugandan intergovernmental ties
we outline their dynamic development
on high level in october 2019
the president of the country of vermont
slovenia took part in russia-africa
summit and economic forum in sochi
talks between russian president and the
leader of uganda took place
these talks gave an impetus to the
development of russian
ghandian copyright different areas
including energy mining agriculture
medicine pharmaceuticals
the legal basis of our relations is uh
developing
and uh since 2015 in the
inter-government russian ugandan
commission economic and scientific
technical cooperation has been working
successfully we're glad to congratulate
our
eugenie and friends on their national
holiday and would like to express our
certitude
that the traditional amicable relations
will be uh further developed as well as
brutal collaboration for the benefit of
the peoples of the two countries
as well as interests of the peace and
stability in east african region
usually we show prosperity and
well-being
but our expert did not put it down in
the text but i would like to say it on
my
own behalf and on the 10th of october
the republic of fiji is celebrating the
50th anniversary of its independence
for practically 100 years this country
was
attention to our american attention of
our american colleagues
british colony its release paved out the
way to
its development
of its own statehood and nation building
we confirm our willingness to further
consolidate
uh various mutually beneficial ties with
fiji
including on the emergence of the
general assembly
sessions in the form of russia and
development island countries of the
southern part of the pacific and close
to this anniversary we would like to
wish our amicable
friend the people of fiji good health
prosperity and happiness uh and the 12th
of october is the republic of equatorial
genie celebrating its 62nd
anniversary of its independence
gaining freedom was difficult for the
people of the country
the state was under the colonial
oppression since the emergence in the
16th century
of first settlers from portugal
and in the end of the 18th century it
came under the control of spain
of course the attempts of europeans to
impose
their rules for encountered resistance
from local tribe and after the
proclamation of independence
our country has been providing help
to equatorial genie and now the
bilateral test
uh characterized by the atmosphere of
friendship and trust mutual
confidence and the dynamic political
dialect
is maintained and to give a strong
impetus to the development of russia
equatorial genius relations was given by
the meeting between
russian president putin and president of
the equatorial
of equatorial genie tedor obiang
saga in 1929 during which
it was outlined how to further develop
mutually beneficial
of this country we congratulate our
friends on this national holiday wish
them peace prosperity and well-being
we can proceed to the questions i am
ready
so let's give the floor to the
journalists who will
address us online
yes please
i'm listening to you do you have any
questions
yes please your questions you can ask
your questions
i'm listening to you are there any
questions if there are some
let's formulate them can i ask a
question yes of course i'm listening to
you
yes of course thank you
saeed afghanian informal uh
new news agency how can you comment on
this statement by trump on the
first coming uh withdrawal of
american troops from afghanistan
how can it influence the course of the
inter-afghanian
talks as for the
inter afghani talks and their stalled
character i have already commented on
that
as for the statement of the american
president
concerning the withdrawal
of troops or their replacement
or their deployment i believe
we should not judge by some statements
we should judge by the actions
when it happens we will comment on them
now it's already
a tradition that there are statements
that have been pronounced for decades
but
that haven't been implemented or have
been implemented in the wrong way when
there are elections will comment on them
thank you are there any other questions
yes please
the question is from
a news agency they it regards the
efforts
russia is applying to settle
nagorno-karabakh
conflict and the intergovernmental
committee
of the e eu will take
place tomorrow in the country even
though
the uh
you know the first comment committee of
the
eurasian intergovernmental council
has to take place it's the fifth
uh maintaining of the kind it will
address the current uh
topics regarding the functioning of the
uh
union it is impossible to postpone them
also the issues of the strategic
development of the organization will be
analyzed
as for the inaugural box settlement
this problem is not included in the
agenda
are there any more questions
i have two short questions the first one
due to military actions and hostilities
in nagorno-karabakh
by armenia azerbaijan and kyrgyzstan
did russian citizens ask for help
and do russian embassies uh receive such
demands or even the ministry itself
and the second question regards
the visits of political leaders
will russia try to
raise once again the questions of
the russian citizens coming
back there did i understand you
correctly that the second questions
regarding the
elections in the united states
yes uh in the context of the elections
as well
let's start with the second question we
cannot predict their results
first of all we need them to take place
then bearing into bearing in mind
the statements by the us political
leaders representatives of different
parties
and other officials
we need them to accept their own results
and after that we will work on bilateral
relations
so we cannot talk about it before it
happens it's impossible
as for the addresses of our citizens
due to the aggression of the
nagorno-karabakh conflict i would like
to say that
it's difficult for me to
devise this question because
because of the pandemic our embassies
all over the world
have been in constant contact with
russian citizens
in every country resolving many
questions
the questions of their repatriations
and assistance with many other questions
like documents
some family matters
financial aid
so our embassies our missions are in
close contact with russian citizens in
all countries of the world each day we
try to solve these
problems when we receive them
if a person needs to address
our embassy or mission
they can do that many of our consulates
consular departments and embassies work
in the same
mode as local
authorities due to their pandemic
confinement current time and
different restrictions but each day you
receive some telephone calls
messages letters from our citizens of
course
the aggravation of the conflict you've
mentioned
did not lead to their decrees just in
contrast
awesome do you have any other questions
yes please
i do not hear you i see that you are
speaking but i do not hear you
forgive me can you hear me now yes now i
can hear you
technical problems
news front bulgari
we would like to ask a question about
nagorno-karabakh settlement
on the 7th of october
head of our tag sent
a call to the osce suggesting to create
an international counterterrorism
coalition
in the context of settlement in agony
karabakh
has russia received such a call
and can you comment upon it if the call
was sent to the osce
it is the oc that it is addressed to but
i will
get the relevant information on the
matter do you have any other questions
if you do not have any other questions i
will turn to the questions that we
received
from before our briefing bumper asks the
following question
tomorrow in berlin a trial starts
i believe the question was sent recently
trial against a citizen accused of
killing congo shrilly
stating that their killing was committed
by order from russian authorities
a political decision was taken
in berlin regarding the sentence that
zokolov will receive
who is accused of shamil basarez killing
one of the
heads of the terrorist group in north
caucasus
who lived in germany by andre and elias
it is naive to believe that the german
justice system will be objective and
unbiased she previously provided him
with a refugee status all the rules and
the trial proceedings are already
determined
there is no doubt that the
blame for an attack against hingashvili
a criminal who has had many enemies
throughout his uh
life due to his his actions in the
criminal world
of different countries will fall
as has also been stated in the media to
russian state
authorities this method has been imposed
on the german
society for many years through
information
campaigns which are backed up by the
statements from representatives of the
german political establishment
and the groundless accusations regarding
state institutes
being involved in the hungarius killing
are based on
media publications which are in turn
based on pseudo investigations
valencia for example has been accused
many times of spreading
false information
such information has been refuted
repeatedly
the fact that the case of hangashvili is
politicized is evidenced by
the fact that two diplomatic
employees in germany were sent out
under a false pretext since russian law
enforcement allegedly
was non-cooperative in regards to the
investigation of a crime
committed in germany russian relevant
authorities
have been in close contact with their
german colleagues and have been
responded to
inquiries and requests of legal
assistance and are ready in spite of the
politicization of the case
from the side of official berlin
continue to cooperate
in this regard a comprehensive
command comment was given by diplomatic
contacts
and channels also in the course of the
meeting of the president
of our country with the german
chancellor
in 2019 as well as during the press
conference of
the russian president as a result of
that meeting
in the principled field that the hunger
philly case
is one of the flagrant
provocations against russia
such as for example russia's involvement
alleged involvement
in a cyber attack against bundestag
there were different opinions regarding
this matter and we have covered it
many times and we have provided our
arguments and our position as well as
the story
with the navalny
which have been initiated by the
germany's uh by the german authorities
in the framework of the anti-russian
track
if berlin continues to pursue this
policy
it can be fraught with an exacerbation
of the situation in our bilateral
relations
another question we received regarding
the decision
uh of an anti-money polio
regulator to impose fines against gas
from another
five companies gazprom is constantly on
the mind
of our partners
including warsaw obviously it is another
politically motivated attempt to
put pressure on the russian gas exporter
who for many years have been providing
natural gas to european consumers we are
not surprised by
warsaw's attempts to use dubious methods
including measures which are outside of
poland's
jurisdiction to slow down the
construction of the north stream too
this decision made by the office to
protect the competition
is made in order to
please washington and use european
union's resources
in order to create
an alternative hub to transfer american
lng
to western european countries it is
deplorable
that seeking their all own self-serving
interest
warso despite the name of the authority
that took the decision continues to
flout principles of good faith
competition
and interests of european consumers
lmg tv asked a question regarding the
negotiations in helsinki between the
representatives of the us
and russia regarding weapons control we
will commend once again
responding to the question
american statement says that
considerable headway
was made at the negotiations and we were
asked to comment upon
this event we have commented upon this
on the 5th of october in houston there
was a regular meeting
between russian and american
representatives vice
foreign minister sergey ryakov
participated in the meaning
from america businessly participated
they continued to discuss the situation
in weapons control field we informed our
american colleagues
our vision regarding the strategic level
which could take into account the
national security considerations
as well as principles of stability
will once again call the us to extend
the star treaty without any
preconditions
we believe that here we should
extend it for five years we believe
that american approaches foreign are a
balance to
foundation to further work we hope that
our proposal will be analyzed by
our american counterparts and we will
receive a positive response
for now
it would be uh too early to talk about
any concrete headway made in this
field we continue to search for common
ground we are ready to cooperate
but perhaps american partners believe
that considerable headway
is simply the fact that we are holding a
dialogue
from this point of view yes we did
indeed make
considerable progress another answer
another question lithuanian bill
regarding latvia's historic lands
lithuanian same
received from the president ebill
there is uh a warning about reserving
historic
uh memory or form about is
in scope and we would like to hear your
comments
on this topic latvia's president indeed
submitted to
the same such initiative
in this bill referencing the fact that
peace agreement has already expired a
legal uh belonging to latvia of a
territory
decided russia's position is well-known
or border control
issues are covered by
the agreement on the border between
russia and latvia
from 2007 i would like to remind you
that the signature of the document was
preceded by the adoption of
latvia's government of an explanatory
declaration
it referenced the peace agreement of
it was seen as a factual
identification of border claims
territory claims
and there were certain prayer conditions
from our side in order to sign
a border agreement between our country
so attempt of the latvian president to
put into question the
existing legal concepts that we see
as strange and provocatry
another matter
received it from many parties how could
you comment upon the idea
of the possibility of armenia requesting
help from the csto
i would like to state that our
leadership has provided
thorough comments upon this matter
[Music]
and this is everything i wanted to tell
you
if you have no further questions i would
like to
thank you for your participation and for
your attention
thank you goodbye
you